die dramatische schmelze in der
antarktis geht immer schneller
vonstatten wenn das gesamte antarktis
schmelzen würde würde der globale
meeresspiegel um unglaubliche 58 meter
ansteigen diese warnung kommt jetzt von
einem internationalen forschungsteam ist
die antarktis noch zu retten
jetzt ein klick zum science fiction gibt
es täglich neue science videos abonniert
den kanal gerne herzlich willkommen
vielen dank für den themenvorschlag aus
der messenger community wir da rein
kommt erfahrt ihr am ende des filmes 219
milliarden tonnen pro jahr eine
unvorstellbare zahl doch so viel eis hat
die antarktis im mittel jedes jahr in
den jahren 2012 bis 2017 verloren das
ist fast dreimal so viel wie in den
jahren davor auf diese ergebnisse kommt
ein internationales forschungsteam um
andy sheppard von der university ließ
zitat land unseren analysen ist es in
den letzten zehn jahren zu einer
beschleunigung des massen verlust in der
antarktis gekommen demnach tragen die
antarktis derzeit zu einem höheren
anstieg des meeresspiegels bei als je
zuvor in den vergangenen 25 jahren vor
allem in der westantarktis ist der masse
verlust am größten aber auch in der
ostantarktis sieht es lange nicht mehr
so gut aus wie in den jahren bis 2012
denn bis zu diesem zeitpunkt hatte es
durch massiven schneefall eine zunahme
der eismasse gegeben doch auch das ist
offensichtlich längst geschichte in den
fünf jahren von 2012 bis 2017 gab es
allein in dieser region an jährlichen
verlust von 28 milliarden tonnen eis das
alles sind die ergebnisse von insgesamt
44 internationalen organisationen die
sich zusammengeschlossen hatten um den
eisverlust in der antarktis zu
kalkulieren unterstützt wurden sie dabei
auch von esa und nasa konkret beziehen
sich die forscherinnen forscher auf 24
satelliten gestützte eismasse schätzung
diese wurden mit verschiedenen
messmethoden analysiert mit der messung
der schwerkraft der höhenmessung und der
sogenannten input output methode hierbei
werden der zuwachs und der verlust von 1
gegeneinander gerechnet als geht
beispielsweise durch das schmelzen und
das kalben der gletscher verloren neues
eis kommt hingegen durch schneefall
hinzu das ergebnis
das eisschild der antarktis hat seit
1992 insgesamt etwa drei billionen
tonnen eis verloren
mit dieser menge könnte man ganz
deutschland rund acht meter hoch mit
wasser bedeckt
eine unvorstellbare menge doch eben
nicht nur die reine wassermenge ansicht
macht den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern ziemlich viel sorgen
sondern eben auch die geschwindigkeit 40
prozent des verlustes passierten der
studie zufolge in den vergangenen fünf
jahren
das ist schon eine krasse ansage
allerdings es gibt unsicherheiten
schließlich werden keine neuen daten
präsentiert sondern die vorherigen
studien werden zusammengeführt
beispielsweise schwanken die
schneemengen pro jahr enorm auch die
höhlen änderung die gemessen worden sind
sind gering und bergen würde gefahr dass
auch kleinere messfehler größere
auswirkungen haben könnten um zu sehen
wie sich das heißt tatsächlich verändert
wären satellitenmission notwendig die
sich nahtlos aneinander reihen doch die
allgemeinen trends die das
forschungsteam vorstellt sind
keinesfalls von der hand zu weisen fest
steht also der eisverlust geschieht
immer schneller und der hauptsächliche
tatort ist die westantarktis hier
brechen eiskappen und schärfe so schnell
auseinander wie man es sich bisher in
den schlimmsten albträumen nicht
vorgestellt hatte und auch die
ostantarktis kann die konsequenzen
daraus nicht mehr mit starkem schneefall
ausgleichen bremsen oder gar stoppen
schon jetzt hat die antarktis wohl acht
millimeter zum anstieg des
meeresspiegels beigetragen ging erst
einmal wenig doch da wird in zukunft
noch einiges dazukommen eine weitere
aktuelle studie hat sich zeitgleich
damit auseinandergesetzt was der anstieg
des meeresspiegels bedeuten wird in
zukunft rechnet das forschungsteam mit
einem anstieg von einem bis zwei
zentimetern pro jahr das kann man
vergleichen mit der letzten kaltzeit
tirol agierten die großen eisschilde in
europa und nordamerika in den kommenden
50 jahren könnte die antarktis im besten
fall lediglich sechs zentimeter zum
weltweiten anstieg des meeresspiegels
beitrage im worst case könnten es aber
auch sie
25 cm seien dazu einer der beteiligten
forscher martin siegert einige der
veränderungen mit denen die antarktis
konfrontiert ist sind bereits ihre
versieben wie der verlust einiger
schelfeis gebiete aber es gibt vieles
was wir verhindern oder rückgängig
machen können entscheidungen die im
nächsten jahrzehnt getroffen werden
bestimmen welche entwicklung realisiert
wird und noch mal für alle klima
skeptiker es geht hier nicht um eines
das im wasser schwimmt und zu keiner
volumen änderung führt also keinem
anstieg des meeresspiegels es geht um
eis das sich auf dem festland der
antarktis ist also auf dem kontinent
befindet und dort verdunstet oder über
gletscher ins meer gelangt so oder so
führt es zur steigerung des
meeresspiegels wir müssen also dringend
handeln und wir handeln hier bei pixum
übrigens auch kriegs- und wird werbefrei
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal
mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir
die werbung für einen monatlichen video
ab werdet also mitglied hier unter dem
video draufklicken oder auf den link in
der video beschreibung für einen kleinen
beitrag bekommt er dazu noch einige
extras wenn er immer garantiert über
aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt
dann endet mich übrigens bei whatsapp
dann bekommt ihr den link zum video vor
allen anderen von mir persönlich auf
euer handy einfach hier draufklicken und
darunter geht es weiter dafür auch
draufklicken mit klimawandel bestätigt
skeptiker endgültig widerlegt bis dann
bleib dran